In the 1970s thousands of Chickenheads rained
from the sky in Europe, making foxes and other
wildlife confused and very happy. Why? They were
filled with a vaccine to fight the deadliest
virus known to humanity – since the 1930s
a rabies epidemic had been sweeping across
wildlife populations in Europe and humans wanted
to finally get rid of the virus once and for all.
Rabies is named after Lyssa, the
ancient Greek spirit of mad rage,
and has been haunting us for at least 4000
years. It can turn animals into angry beasts
and humans into zombies that fear water. But
what makes Lyssa fascinating is not just how
bizarre and deadly its infection is, but also how
incredibly good it is at avoiding our defenses.
Viruses exist on the edge between life and death,
hardly more than a few genetic instructions that
need living cells to multiply. The lyssavirus is
simple even for a virus: It has only five genes,
that is the instructions for five proteins that
let it solve complex problems: Infect a mammal,
avoid its immune system, travel to its brain,
make more of itself and infect new hosts.
Let's see what happens if you get infected.
It all starts with a bite, most likely by a
dog carrying millions of viruses in its saliva,
pushing them deep into the tissue. The goal is
your nerve cells, your neurons. They are living
electrochemical wires, transferring signals
throughout your body, and can stretch for up
to 1.5 meters, with their cellular machinery
on one end and a terminal on the other.
The terminal is where cells talk to each other,
by passing chemicals that convey information.
Lyssa probably binds to the receptors
that are crucial for this process
and slips inside the unsuspecting nerve cells.
Inside, the virus has to solve a big problem.
It needs to get to the cellular machinery to
take over the cell and make more viruses
– and because neurons are pretty long,
this can be far away. There
is a solution at hand though:
Cells have microtubules spanning their
insides that give them structural integrity.
But they also provide a track system
for a specialized delivery system:
Dynein motors are actual motors that use energy
and deliver packages. They are made from 50
different proteins, ten times more than the virus,
and look like a little pair of shoes. Lyssa uses
one of its five proteins to hijack this amazing
system and order it to head for the nucleus.
What is the immune system doing to prevent
all of that? Well, unfortunately not much.
Usually when a virus attacks your civilian cells
are crucial in activating your immune response.
They notice that they have been infected and
release hundreds of thousands of a special family
of proteins: The interferons that, well, interfere
with viruses. We’ll have to simplify a lot,
but in a nutshell, Interferons alert your
immune system to make antivirus weapons.
But they do much more: they tell civilian
cells to turn down their protein factories
for a while – which means that viruses
can’t replicate efficiently anymore.
And interferons tell your cells to become super
transparent, which is important, because how
can your immune cells notice that your civilian
cells are infected when viruses hide inside them?
Your body solves this by creating display windows
into their insides, called MHC class I molecules.
Cells constantly produce stuff to stay alive,
and to showcase to your immune cells what is
going on inside them, they take random samples
of their products and put them into these
tiny display windows to give a peek inside.
Interferon tells your cells to make WAY more
display windows and become super transparent.
If a cell is infected and forced to make virus
parts, your immune cells will see these parts
in a window and order the infected cell to
kill itself – and all the viruses trapped
within. This is one of the most powerful
methods of wiping out a viral infection.
Unfortunately Lyssa blocks your neurons
from making interferons and stays basically
invisible to your immune system. In contrast
to many other viruses, when it replicates,
it doesn’t kill its host, which
would also trigger alarm systems.
Instead it stealthily jumps from neuron to
neuron, very slowly making its way to your brain.
This phase can take weeks to
months and very rarely even years
and depends on a bunch of things, like if the bite
was in your face or foot or how many viruses got
into your muscles. Lyssa is a patient monster.
Until it reaches its goal: Your brainstem.
Finally, the immune system catches
on that something isn’t right
and reacts. It dispatches some of your most
powerful antivirus cells, Killer T Cells,
to seek and kill infected cells and wipe out the
enemy. In other viral infections this would be a
turning point, but in rabies the T cells are
rushing towards their doom. Simple Lyssa with
its 5 proteins plays a uno reverse card, using
the immune system’s ingenuity against itself.
Your central nervous system is a very fragile
part of your body and so the immune system has
to be very careful. A few haywire immune
cells in your brain is a quick way to die.
So they aren’t free to enter your nervous
system, they have to be be invited in
and can be kicked out. To protect themselves, your
nerve cells can order T Cells to self-destruct,
if they think they are overreacting. And Lyssa
figured out a way to make infected neurons express
this order. So as your powerful defense cells
arrive – they are ordered to commit suicide.
Now the virus infiltrates the brain stem. Once
this stage is reached you are going to die.
How Lyssa Kills
One of the most irritating things about
the Lyssavirus is that we still don’t
know exactly how and why an infected person dies.
Our usual idea of viruses causing
damage is by multiplying rapidly,
killing their host cells once they have made
enough copies, triggering a massive immune
reaction that also does a lot of damage. But
this doesn’t seem to be what happens here.
Brain tissue of rabies patients shows
minimal, sometimes non-existent damage.
Instead of murdering everything in sight, it
is currently thought that lyssa wreaks havoc
by messing up the neuron communication inside your
brain, so much so, that it can’t function anymore.
It attacks the brain and leads to symptoms
like confusion, aggression and paralysis.
Now the virus begins to leave. Still traveling
through neurons, it migrates away from the brain
and heads for the salivary glands. This is
remarkable, because after traveling in one
direction the virus reverses its course. After
decades of study we don’t know how this works.
Lyssa ends up saturating your saliva
ready for the irate mammal to bite another
and repeat the cycle. While this seems
like the beginning of a Zombie outbreak,
luckily there are no known cases of a human
biting another and spreading rabies this way.
Now the end is near. You are rapidly developing
encephalitis, a swelling of the brain with many
unpleasant neurological symptoms, from lethargy
to paralysis. Slowly at first, and then suddenly,
organ after organ fails as you slip into a coma.
There is no known effective therapy, barely anyone
has ever survived Lyssa once symptoms begin to
show. It is by far the deadliest virus we know.
Except, there is actually something
that could save you – a vaccine.
Rabies was one of the first diseases
humans developed a vaccine for.
As vaccines do, it prepares your immune system for
a future attack, so it has the right weapons ready
in high numbers. The horrific tricks of simple
Lyssa don’t work once you are vaccinated. And the
vaccine is special for another reason – because
Lyssa is so slow in the first few weeks, it can
be given to you after you have been exposed. So
you can still be vaccinated after you have been
bitten by an animal. Which is super important
if you’ve had contact with a sick wild animal,
say a bat, because you often don’t
even notice a bite from tiny teeth.
Rabies is a monster. One that has followed
our species around for thousands of years,
that our ancestors were terrified of and rightly
so. It still kills around 60,000 people each year,
almost half of them children. We are far from
eradicating this monster – It lurks in the
shadows, in forests and animals of all kinds,
ready to return in greater numbers if we ever
forget how to keep it at bay, or if we continue
the trend of being suspicious of vaccines.
Let us hope that one day
humanity slays this monster,
so it can become like most
monsters: Part of our imagination.
There are much deeper levels
of knowledge to explore about
rabies than the glimpse we just showed you.
But digging into sources and
scientific information on your own
can be intimidating. So we partnered with our
friends from Brilliant to create an interactive
course with hands-on lessons to guide you through
some of the concepts we showed in this video.
Brilliant is an interactive learning
tool with over 60 courses in math,
science, and computer science. They make
science accessible with a hands-on approach.
Think of it as a one-on-one tutoring version
of a Kursgesagt video. You’ll experiment with
how fast the virus can reach your brain based on
its protein makeup or run simulations on Rabies’
genetic evolution, to explore how mutations
created the deadly virus we know today.
You can do things like manipulate energy
to see how black holes are formed,
or control the expansion of space itself to
determine the ultimate fate of the universe.
To get some behind-the-scenes-science-coaching
on space and biology and many more topics,
go to Brilliant.org SlashNutshell and sign
up for free. And there’s an extra perk for
kurzgesagt viewers: the first 200 people to use
the link get 20% off their annual membership,
which unlocks all of Brilliant’s courses
in math, science, and computer science.
We love to go down a rabbit hole
with our research – Brilliant will
take you by the hand to come along on the ride.